Oh this'll do the derivative right it
tells you how is this situation changing
it's what we call a rate of change in
this case the rate of change is I guess
what would you call it
infections per day or something like
that right we don't want to know about
this we know it's always increasing it's
always positive right what we want to
know is has that thing changing how is
the derivative changing so I need to not
just differentiate to get this I
actually need to differentiate again to
find how this rate of change is changing
can I say that one more time I want to
know how the rate of change is changing
is it getting faster and faster are we
in trouble or is it getting slower and
slower where actually it's working okay
so what I'm looking for is the
derivative of the derivative that's a
bit long and awkward to say so instead
what I call this is the second
derivative and so to distinguish between
these I actually even accidentally set
it about 1 minute ago we called the
derivative which we've just been calling
do you want DX or whatever f - we call
the derivative the first derivative
because what happens when you
differentiate once but if you want to
know something about how that thing is
changing how the rate of change is
changing then you have to differentiate
a second time we call the second
derivative okay so this is how the rate
of change is changing okay now this is a
practical example I actually want to
help you understand this with something
that we can work with so I would like
you to graph again just roughly and this
guy here I would normally ask you to
graph it I would say there's the
equation right there y equals x times X
minus 3 or square and then I would say
off you go graphic but actually that
would take too much time so I'm just
handing the raft to you because I'm um
I'm nice and gracious like that so
here's the graph I'm you will need the
equation though
because in a second we're gonna
differentiate this and work with it okay
so if I give you a function y equals x
times X minus 3 or squared I'd like us
to work out what's going on here in
regard to these things yeah ok so to
differentiate this it's not in a very
nice form to differentiate at this
particular moment I'm it's factorized
which makes it easier to graph but I
have to use product rule and I'd really
like to avoid that if I can okay so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to suggest
if you've already written the function
like I asked let's expand this in an
expanded polynomial is generally easier
to differentiate okay this guy's not
hard to expand what's X minus 3 all
squared what do you get square the first
which gives you x squared you double the
product and then you square the other
one so plus 9 fantastic ok so I've done
the square and now I'm going to expand
out and have numeral brackets so that
leaves me with what on the next line
execute yep minus 6x squared plus 9x
fantastic okay so now that I've got my
function in about is easier form as
possible to differentiate I want us to
differentiate it okay so let's go to the
first one the first derivative okay
dy on DX this is easy we could do this
in our sleep right
someone told me yeah go ahead hold on
3x squared you have you're on the right
track we've got to bring the power the
front first and then reduce yep
minus 12x plus 9 fantastic okay let's
just pause there before we go any
further okay
now you might notice on this graph that
I've given you I've put a whole bunch of
points coordinates okay and the reason
why is because I want to understand what
does this tell us about the graph at
different places okay so what I've done
is that here's one I prepared earlier
right on this graph you don't write this
by the way because it's gonna get really
messy really fast on your graph I've
taken this thing our derivative and I've
just sub some values in at those
particular spots to see what the
derivative actually is equal to
this is what it's actually equal to at
those particular spots let me zoom in so
you can see sorry my writing is a little
bit small okay what kind of things stand
out to you what do you notice any
interesting characteristics the jump out
of you there's two station of race
fantastic and you can see them where
I've marked in the derivative is equal
to zero okay what else do you say yeah
so there's like a symmetry to it that's
funny there's a symmetry to the
derivative values I wonder why there
would be a symmetry to the derivatives
I'm just gonna park that thought for a
second okay what what else do you notice
anything else you know so you might know
I put colors on here the colors are not
accidental when I think the colors
signify positive and negative okay now
this is important because looking at the
language we developed earlier right
let's use red to start with over here on
the left hand side right how would we
describe this well the gradient is
positive so this section of the graph
it's increasing do you agree up it goes
right but then you get to the stationary
point and suddenly you're like oh this
is going to have this downward
trajectory so we don't call that
increasing we call it we don't call it
increasing we call it decreasing thank
you okay we're away all right so this
section here right as you slide down the
roller coaster and then of course your
first derivative it changes back to
positive and you can go ahead you can
test these values out if you like that's
like three and a half is the x value
there if you put three and a half into
this you should get three point seven
five okay so this is what the first
three have to tell us we already knew
this right we would say increasing
decreasing that's the information this
gives you okay but I said right from the
outset I was trying to understand this
graph this logistic model right so that
means we actually have to think of this
sky the next derivative down okay now
let me catch up for reasons that'll
become clear in a second I'm not going
to write the proper notation for it
because it's weird and warrants its own
explanation so I'm just gonna really do
the really write down second derivative
what does it equal to and thankfully
you've already had people ready yeah
we'll come to it we'll come to it it's
six X take away 12 yeah okay now this is
even simpler because every time you're
differentiate you go down your
polynomial gets you know goes from 3 to
2 to 1 so it's very simple you could put
the values in for yourself but again I
wanted to save you at a time so here's
the same function